on est bien peu de chose et mon amie la
rose me l'a dit ce matin
alors je suis né baptisé ne rentrent et
je me suis épanoui
bonjour et bienvenue pour votre
cinquième épisode du petit émir la
semaine dernière nous étions lim de la
montagne pour un casting très percutant
en compagnie d'hélène la
musicothérapeute nous avions ainsi
découvert les talents de marco david
nicholas et cédric
cette semaine nous nous rendons au
centre de la ressource ou marica va
revoir sur scène les élèves des épisodes
1 et 3 lors d'un spectacle donné devant
du public ses premiers choix vont-ils
être conforté va-t-elle avoir des
surprises pour le savoir partons tout de
suite en coulisses où les élèves se
préparent avant leur entrée en scène
beaucoup
oh
oui
le stress se fait ressentir en coulisses
mais nos comédiens sont enfin prêts à
entrer en scène et s'est enquis dean et
son ballon qui se jette à l'eau en
premier
joie
après ce one man show c'est maintenant
au tour de la troupe de la ressource
avec un spectacle de mime
à présent place aux élèves d'adrien
cerneaux et leur spectacle de mime avec
marionnettes et ballon
oh
en courant
oui
et
ouais
g
marica a désormais une idée plus précise
du potentiel de chaque élève en
situation de spectacle donc j'ai vu
aussi adeline et zidane qui ont vraiment
une présence sur scène et de les voir
devant un public me rassure par rapport
aux quartiers
la semaine prochaine nous retrouverons
marica lors de ses premières décisions
nous la verrons affiner ses choix par
une série d'entretiens individuels avec
les jeunes comédiens seront ils
suffisamment motivé pour participer au
spectacle du petit émir vous découvrirez
leurs ressentis dans le prochain épisode
à très bientôt